[Music]
well the cynic would say ha solar energy
that's for Hollywood millionaires and
I've heard that so often that we're
gonna live in solar houses and it never
happened so ha well you see there's a
reason that we don't live in the solar
age and it doesn't have anything to do
with solar cells at all you see there's
a missing link that's what we don't have
wind power and solar power everywhere
and the missing link is something we
forget and that is storage the battery a
hundred years ago Thomas Edison and
Henry Ford were friends they would
vacation together and they were rivals
of course and they had a bet what would
energize the 20th century
well Edison said the battery well
Ford said no it's gonna be the internal
combustion engine
well people said the solution to that is
obvious the the internal combustion
engine is dangerous because gasoline
engines will explode batteries will not
explode but gasoline will and having a
gas station on every block that's
ridiculous
that's stupid so many people said that
it's obvious Edison is gonna win we're
not gonna have gas pumps on every block
and we're not gonna have explosions take
place in our highways well guess what
happened the opposite happened and that
is Henry Ford was right at least for the
20th century and now General Motors
General Motors recently announced that
they can see the time when they will
phase out completely the internal
combustion engine this is huge
think about that 50% of our carbon
dioxide production comes from the
transportation sector and General Motors
is already talking about phasing out the
internal combustion engine so what's the
problem the problem is the battery the
lowly battery that everybody forgets you
see we all know Moore's law computer
power doubles every 18 months but
Moore's law only applies to ultraviolet
edging on computers silicon wafers it
doesn't apply for solar cells storage is
the basic problem there's no Moore's law
for the battery however now that
inventors are getting wind of this we
now see new
energy new creativity new ideas and so
the price of battery power is dropping
by about 7% a year this means
opportunities for the super battery is
no accident that Elon Musk of Tesla
Motors has made the battery a priority
he wants to market these super batteries
so that when the Sun doesn't shine and
the winds don't blow you can still have
large quantities of solar power
he's also marketing these batteries for
industries because what happens if you
can't necessarily make peak summer and
peak winter demands of power
why should a utility have to generate
this gigantic infrastructure to generate
electricity just for peak summer and
peak winter that's where the super
battery comes in and so with the price
of batteries dropping I think we're
going to see the economics of solar and
wind turn the other way so they are
competitive with fossil fuels
[Music]